abdou bonjour aux dont j'ai peur c'est
votre rendez-vous avec l'actualité
politique et parlementaire de cette
semaine parlement hebdo à la une
aujourd'hui une mission qui vaut de l'or
christine boutin sous pression après les
révélations du canard enchaîné
9500 euros mensuels pour rédiger un
rapport sur la mondialisation
critiqué de toute part l'ancien ministre
est contrainte de renoncer à sa
rémunération querelle de famille chez
les écolos beazley et amabilité lors de
la convention sur l'avenir d'europe
écologie avec 2012 comme ligne d'horizon
et le choix entre la candidature de
cécile duflot l'étoile montante des
verts ou celle de l'ancienne juge eva
joly
rama yade taclé par le chef de l'état
pour ses critiques sur l'hébergement de
l'équipe de france en afrique du sud en
conseil des ministres nicolas sarkozy
demande d'éviter les petites phrases à
tendance populiste
alors que s'ouvre la coupe du monde la
secrétaire d'état aux sports de plus en
plus marginalisé au sein du gouvernement
et avec nous pour commenter l'actualité
françois de rugy bonjour merci d'être
avec nous sur ce plateau
vous êtes député de loire atlantique
l'un des trois députés verts à
l'assemblée avec yves cochet noël mamère
vous êtes le plus jeune de ce trio
écologistes d'ailleurs l'un des plus
jeunes de l'assemblée que vous avez
rejoint il ya trois ans à l'âge de 34
ans vous êtes membre de la commission
des finances également lieu stratégique
où il faut être aviez vous dit et à
propos de finances justement françois de
rugy vous êtes l'un des très rares à
jouer la transparence totale sur vos
revenus vous les données sur votre site
internet 6088 euros nets mensuels dont
5200 d'indemnités de députés vous dites
qu'il faut lever le tabou donc afficher
la transparence en pleine affaire boutin
est ce qu'il faudrait que tout le monde
fasse comme vous je crois que ce serait
bien que les règles changent aujourd'hui
c'est sur la base du volontariat et nous
sommes assez peu de volontaires je crois
qu'en matière de transparence notamment
sur la fameuse indemnité de frais de
mandat que les députés ont et c'est tout
à fait normal que nous ayons cette
indemnité qui nous permet de fonctionner
dans notre circonscription moi j'ai par
exemple 1200 euros de loyer tous les
mois pour ma permanence je fais un petit
journal
bien le payer d'imprimer le distribuer
mais ce serait bien quand même que tout
le monde dise tous les ans voilà quelles
sont les dépenses qui ont été assurées
grâce à cette indemnité
moi je souhaite aussi que on aille plus
loin par rapport notamment à la retraite
des députés
il va y avoir le débat sur les retraites
quoi qu'on pense de la réforme préparée
par le gouvernement peut être que nous
en reparlerons il n'y pas normal il
n'est pas supportable par nos
concitoyens de voir que il ya un régime
spécial
si avantageux pour les parlementaires
qui est très déficitaire résidents des
deux assemblées ont vu eric woerth
semaine sûrement pour pour en parler moi
je souhaite qu'on aille barbe dans les
jours et les semaines qui viennent et
qu'on agisse qu'on se contente pas d'en
parler
allez si vous le valez bien on va
commencer la semaine avec évidemment la
journée du lundi qui bruisse encore des
noms d'oiseaux que ce sont envoyés
pendant le week-end vos amis écologistes
alors propos recueillis la structuration
d'europe écologie est un bide total à
propos du numéro deux des verts
jean-vincent placé crétins on répond à
daniel cohn bendit d'europe écologie
voilà ce qu'on aura en substance ce
refus retenu pardon du rassemblement du
week-end quand les écologistes renoue
avec les vieux démons de lait des
rivalités
c'est un sujet de jérémy hartmann depuis
les succès électoraux d'europe écologie
on pensait que les guéguerres internes
était oublié que ses membres avaient
enfin découvert les vertus de la
discipline mais samedi sur la scène de
la cigale à paris les leaders du
mouvement sont retombés dans leurs
travers du passé noms d'oiseaux
règlement de compte à distance daniel
cohn bendit et cécile duflot ont offert
un spectacle vaudevillesque aux quelques
500 militants venus assister aux débats
de quelqu un qu un certain âge elle se
voulait c'est là où une vieille est inné
ce n'est pas du niveau de crespin ne
nous ont pas ils ne nous mentons pas en
mai
hasard ou coïncidence la cible des
critiques n'étaient pas dans la salle ce
jour là jean vincent placé est très
chahutée pour les propos qu'il a répandu
dans la presse la veille avec six mille
signataires le numéro deux des verts
qualifie de beats total la campagne
d'adhésion à europe écologie quant à eva
joly pressentie pour être la candidate
du mouvement à la présidentielle de 2012
il la traite de vieille éthique quand il
ya un malaise évident est que à peine
que j'arrive ici tout le monde ne parle
que d'un problème il faut en parler
on n'est pas quand même des hypocrites
toto parce qu'il ya des journaux il ya
quelques caméras de télévision on va pas
parler de ce qui fâche il faut vider
l'abcès
daniel cohn bendit demande la création
d'un comité d'éthique après cette
polémique interne
cécile duflot a elle aussi désavoué les
propos de son bras droit
la secrétaire nationale des verts se
serait bien passé d'une telle publicité
tout le monde doit quand même avoir
conscience de la responsabilité qu'on a
tous on a une responsabilité et après
j'espère que les uns et les autres
sauront freiner leurs ardeurs du moment
dans cette cacophonie ambiante les
militants n'en savent pas vraiment plus
sur ce que doit devenir en europe
écologie réseau coopérative fédération
rien ne sera tranché avant le congrès
fondateur de novembre prochain
une chose est sûre europe écologie
ressemblera à tout sauf à un parti
traditionnel alors françois de rugy
daniel cohn bendit et jean vincent placé
qui se détestent et qui le montre c'est
mal parti le grand rassemblement
écologiste sont des rêves c'est malvenu
il se trouve que je connais assez bien
les deux personnages car ce sont deux
personnages que je les je suis plutôt
ami avec les deux que ce sont des gens
qui sont plutôt assez bon vivant et
qu'ils sont intelligents politiquement
donc je crois qu'il va le mieux est l'un
et l'autre que ce genre de petites
phrases j'en avais parlé après j'en ai
parlé avec jean vincent placé parce que
je lui ai dit que c'était vraiment comme
je le disais malvenue
c'était des propos totalement déplacé
mais ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
ça me fait un peu penser si vous voulez
europe écologie aujourd'hui c'est un
petit peu comme une famille recomposée
et donc il ya les premières semaines les
premiers mois on est content de refonder
une famille on a été séparée parfois par
la vie etc
et puis au bout d'un certain temps il ya
quand même des tensions il ya des
difficultés parce qu'il faut chacun
forcément de crétin au sein toutes les
femmes iront dans les familles en tout
cas moi je sais de quoi je parle
hier fois des mot plus haut que l'autre
que l'on regrette après on risque de
jean vincent placé n'a pas mis à part le
ton qu'il emploie un peu raison c'est à
dire sur l'échec de la démarche de
daniel cohn bendit quand on voit le très
petit nombre d'adhésions à europe
écologie depuis les régionales
alors ça c'est une vraie question si mes
jambes je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
parler d'échec parce que je crois que la
campagne d'adhésions elle a pas encore
eu lieu
cercle il suffit pas de lancer quelque
chose sur internet 1 c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde ne jure que
par internet par facebook etc
mais là on fait pas un apéro géant on
fait un parti politique et donc quand on
construit un mouvement politique il faut
s'en donner les moyens
or aujourd'hui europe écologie et les
verts ont peu de moyens ça peu de gens
le savent
donc il faut faire une campagne
militante il faut aller voir les gens il
faut aller leur donner de la main à la
main mais vous tendent à des
concurrences pour les verts pas du tout
je crois qu contrat c'est une chance
historique pour les verts de sortir de
leur petit collège de leur petit
coquillage trop centristes pour pour
vous pas du tout alors là moi je trouve
que eva joly au contraire nous a
beaucoup apporté pendant la campagne des
européennes elle a continué et on
accompagne à genève elle aurait pu dire
écoutez moi j'ai été élue députée
européenne je vais faire mon travail de
député européenne ce qu'elle fait très
bien et elle apporte beaucoup au
parlement européen et ce sont des
parlementaires européens de toutes
tendances qui me l'ont dit d'ailleurs
màj au lit plutôt qu'elle duflot pour
2012 pourquoi pas en tout cas moi je
souhaite a dit
6une isle of man site où le mouvement on
sollicite je me présenterais c'est ce
qu'elle vient de dire un journal
norvégien eva joly est franco
norvégienne moi je trouve que c'est une
très bonne idée
sa candidature je la voit d'un très bon
oeil mais celle que celle de cécile
duflot
au jour d'aujourd'hui je pense qu'elle
apporterait plus parce que si vous les
bons mois la campagne présidentielle
pour les écologistes a été un peu
particulière et disons le un peu
difficile nous n'avons pas soyons francs
un présidentiable ou une présidentiable
ni moi ni cécile duflot ni eva joly ni
daniel cohn bendit ne peuvent prétendre
rassemblé assez de suffrages pour être
au deuxième tour de l'élection et
prétendre non mais non il le sait très
bien c'est pour ça qu'il ne veut pas
être candidat d'ailleurs nous n'avons
pas non plus vocation à jouer les tribun
populiste on sait qu'il ya un certain
nombre de candidats à jouer ce rôle-là à
l'extrême gauche ou à l'extrême droite
nous ne sommes pas dans ce registre là
donc il nous faut trouver une
candidature avec une personnalité un peu
décalé et je crois qu eva joly a de ce
point de vue là beaucoup d'atouts car
elle peut rassembler la famille
écologiste elle est avec nous depuis le
début de l'aventuré europe écologie et
en même temps sans doute rassembler
beaucoup d'autres personnes en tout cas
moi il ya des gens qui me le disait
qu'ils viennent me voir en disant ce
sera une bonne candidate
un autre sujet fallait-il lancé une
polémique sur le logement des bleus en
afrique du sud
et ça juste quelques jours avant le
début de la coupe du monde la secrétaire
d'état aux sports ne reçoit pas beaucoup
de soutien
après ces critiques rama yade donc et
surtout pas celui de sa ministre de
tutelle roselyne bachelot c'est un sujet
de thomas souliers aux urnes et avenue
rapp et cela le pezula resort un
établissement cinq étoiles à près de 600
euros la nuit pour cette coupe du monde
en afrique du sud
celle où tu es le plus cher réservé une
équipe nationale coût total un million
d'euros trop clinquant selon rama yade
rapidement taclé par sa ministre de
tutelle
je n'aurais pas choisi cet hôtel
personnellement l'espagne par exemple a
choisi un campus universitaire l'espagne
qui fait quand même partie des équipes
favorites n'est plus temps de faire des
polémiques autour de notre équipe on a
discuté du bien fond
des choix de raymond domenech de ceci de
cela maintenant allez stop on est
derrière notre équipe elle en a besoin
la polémique embarrasse la majorité qui
ne prend pas position et préfère siffler
la fin de la partie
et pour en sortir un peu avec l'humour
parce que je pense qu'il faut avoir un
peu d'humour
la seule chose que nous attendons tous
de l'équipe de france c'est que sur le
terrain le vrai luxe
ce soit qu'elle se comporte comme une
formule 1 à gauche aussi on se refuse à
commenter la polémique mais les propos
de rama yade étonne et selon le ps vont
à l'encontre de sa politique
j'observe qu'elle est la secrétaire
d'état qui a permis n'est pas le plus
important en matière de transformation
du football on a un foot business de
plus en plus lié à l'argent puisqu'elle
et c'est sous son mandat que s'est créée
une nouvelle niche fiscale qui permet en
compensation de la suppression du droit
à l'image
un joueur professionnel de football de
disposer d'un revenu supplémentaire net
d'impôt au final l'histoire ne dit pas
si en cas de défaite prématurée de
l'équipe de france la facture de l'hôtel
sera allégée elle a eu raison
rama yade ou c'était malvenu déplacer
mais je crois que surtout ça pose un
problème pour rama yade
quel est son rôle gouvernement à quoi
elle sert et c'était déjà le problème
quand elle était secrétaire d'état aux
droits de l'homme elle lance des petites
polémiques semble-t-il pour faire parler
d'elle mais quel poids elle assure les
décisions réel de la politique sportive
aujourd'hui ou hier de la politique des
droits de l'homme et je vois un certain
nombre de ministres délégués ou de
secrétaire d'état dans ce gouvernement
qui n'ont visiblement aucun poids sur
rien et qui essaye d'exister comme ça
par des petites phrases dans les médias
moi je trouve ça grave parce que ça
décrédibilise la parole politique et ça
donne l'impression finalement que le
plus utile dans un gouvernement comme
celui de monsieur sarkozy c'est de faire
parler de soi mais c'est pas d'agir or
on attend des ministres ou des
secrétaires d'état qu'ils agissent et
malgré tout elle était parmi les plus
populaires du gouvernement
oui à peut-être parce que justement elle
est finalement assez déconnecté des
affaires du gouvernement et qu'elle ne
gère rien dans la politique du
gouvernement et qu'elle se contente de
commenter les choses soient de son
ministère soit d'ailleurs
allez on va passer maintenant la journée
du mardi
et au ps recule sur le cumul mardi donc
se tenait le conseil national du parti
socialiste en quelque sorte le parlement
du parti martine aubry a fait entériner
le calendrier des primaires telles qu'il
avait été adopté par le bureau
en revanche elle a prudemment battu en
retraite sur le cumul des mandats
une façon d'éviter une guerre interne à
l'échéance des élections sénatoriales et
les noms jardy soulagée elle se laisse
aller un petit signe de victoire
le vote sur la rénovation du parti
n'était pas gagné d'avancé pour martine
aubry
dans une salle comble le parti a
finalement voté quasiment à l'unanimité
pour la rénovation
mais pour obtenir ce consensus la chef
du ps a dû transiger
elle voulait imposer aux sénateurs le
non cumul des mandats dès 2011
face à la fronde elle a reculé que je
proposerai tout en maintenant le nombre
de mieux pour les cénacles modèle 2011
qu'ils puissent s'ils le souhaitent
rester jusqu'en septembre 2012
devant ce choix l'accord entre les
sénateurs et le parti a été conclu in
extremis quelques minutes avant le début
du conseil national les élus de la haute
assemblée sont sortis de leur discrétion
habituelle pour imposer leur point de
vue à la première secrétaire je suis
heureux qu'elle nous ait entendu même si
à un moment donné
le dialogue a été un peu vite c'est le
principe d'intelligence de souplesse de
subtilité qui l'a emporté sur un
principe d'automaticité qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas être entendus pour les
primaires françois hollande était le
seul dans la salle a milité pour un vote
avant l'été
il n'a pas obtenu gain de cause le vote
est programmé en octobre 2011 dans les
couloirs certains pensent déjà à la
prochaine étape et critique l'entente
tacite qui pourrait lier martine aubry à
dominique strauss kahn et ségolène royal
s'il ya peu de candidats parce que il
aurait peu de choses à dire aux français
de proposition à faire à la france elian
de radio qui remplaceront ne croyez pas
les choses soient figées donc
attendez-vous à ce qu' il y ait une
histoire inattendue des primaires cela
ne fait que commencer il y aura
certainement de grandes surfaces
les militants devront encore donner leur
aval au projet défendu par martine aubry
ils voteront le 24 juin prochain elle a
bien fait martine aubry de laisser le
choix aux parlementaires au moins jusqu
aux sénatoriales
moi je retiens surtout le fait qu'il y
ait un engagement extrêmement fort de
voter dès 2012 si nous avons la majorité
et nous les verts nous avons été porteur
de cette revendication de lutte contre
le cumul des mandats depuis longtemps de
respecter pas tellement d'ailleurs un
pour tous en vacances qui me concerne ça
montre bien qu'il faut une loi et donc
moi je voudrais saluer l'action de
martine aubry à la tête du parti
socialiste on sait que c'était un pari
difficile lorsqu'elle a été élue
première secrétaire dans des conditions
difficiles
et depuis elle a remis non seulement le
parti socialiste manifestement en ordre
de marche au travail et elle réussit à
lui faire prendre des décisions fortes
la faire des choix clairs donc c'est une
bonne chose fleurs que vous le pensez à
martine aubry est ce que vous seriez
prêt à participer à cette aventure des
primaires ouvertes aux autres partis il
faudra alors en revanche ça je n'ai pas
compris qu'elle était très ouverte pour
ma part puisque j'ai vu que c'était des
règles essentiellement internes au parti
socialiste il faut avoir le parrainage
d'un syndrome d'élus socialistes etc
je crois que là il ya un autre problème
qui se pose est là il faudrait des
réponses plus claires de la part de
martine aubry c'est qu'il faut d'abord
avant de songer à une primaire commune
par exemple que nous irons quand même un
projet que nous puissions travailler en
commun à une plateforme commune de
propositions pour 2012 avant la
présidentielle un remake dont il avait
été le programme commun dans les années
70 mais qui avait remis
en 81 meilleur et françois mitterrand
avait bien vu qu'il fallait une
stratégie claire et que la question
d'une candidature commune était
secondaire françois mitterrand a été
candidat commun des socialistes et des
communistes à l'époque puis candidats
séparés c'est comme ça qu'il a gagné
d'ailleurs mais en revanche il avait dit
aux français si vous nous donnez la
majorité voilà comment nous gouvernerons
voilà sur quelle base
nous gérerons la france et c'est ce
qu'il faut que nous fassions d'ailleurs
l'exemple de la loi sur le cumul des
mandats
moi je souhaiterais que nous puissions
la déposer ensemble et la travailler
ensemble c'est pas simplement la sphère
du parti socialiste et la sphère de
toute la gauche voire peut-être au-delà
si vous aller seul aux présidentielles
convoyer les primaires quand ça peut pas
donner des idées aux écologistes une
primaire pour départager cécile duflot
eva joly
j'ai toujours été favorable moi je
l'avais écrit au sein des verts il ya
déjà plusieurs années pour 2007
notamment que nous ayons un système qui
associe c'est pas tellement la question
d'avoir des primaires mais c'est de
savoir qui décide et d'avoir une base
large au delà des adhérents d'un parti
nous nous l'avons toujours su avec du
temps avec les adhérents des verts mais
nous souhaitons là enfin moi je
souhaiterais qu'on aille beaucoup plus
large et je crois que ce sera un moyen
notamment de mobiliser pour construire
europe écologie alors fait un pari
peut-être sur ces candidatures en tout
cas mardi
les paris sont ouverts à trois jours du
coup d'envoi de la coupe du monde de
football entre en vigueur la nouvelle
loi sur les jeux en ligne aux opérateurs
17 sites se partagent désormais
officiellement le fabuleux marché des
paris hippiques et sportifs bientôt le
poker
rien que pour le mondial 5 millions de
français se disent prêts à parier qu à
malabo reim
ils sont dix sept 17 sites de jeux
d'argent à avoir reçu un agrément de
l'arjel à être officiellement autorisée
en france pour l'essentiel des sites de
paris sportif le plus urgent à trois
jours de la coupe du monde pour éviter
le déferlement de paris illégaux
le jeu est donc désormais encadré
l'autorité de régulation créé avec la
loi se posent en rempart contre la
fraude avec campagne de communication à
la clé
marre de vous faire plumer jouer
uniquement sur des sites agréés arjel
il y à des messages de prévention il ya
la création d'un appel un numéro d'appel
national pour le conseil aux joueurs en
difficulté
il y a pour la première fois le
financement des centres de prise en
charge des joueurs en difficulté
malgré ces quelques garde-fous avec
l'autorisation de la publicité sur
internet et à la télévision
on craint l'arrivée de nouveaux joueurs
incité par ce nouveau système
le président de l'arjel sont des fonds
immédiatement bien quand on veut inciter
à jouer on ne commence pas par encadrer
et réguler les conditions de cette
publicité c'est ce que l'état a fait il
ne l'avait pas fait précédemment vous
pouviez faire de la publicité notamment
pour les monopoles sans qu'elle soit
encadrée
ou limiter dorénavant il ya des règles
très strictes d'encadrement une
limitation et notamment de protection du
public mineur reste maintenant à
connaître les noms des sites de poker
dont les agréments seront délivrés plus
tard le 28 juin
voilà ce que j'ai signé les écarts dit
est-ce que c'est pas une bonne chose de
légaliser certains sites plutôt que de
laisser les gens parier sur des sites
illégaux et non sécurisés peut-être à ce
moment là on pourrait appliquer ce
raisonnement dans bien d'autres domaines
vous savez il ya aussi le trafic de
drogue de drogues douces dedans du on
pourra dire ah mais il vaut peut-être
mieux légaliser que de laisser les
choses se faire dans l'illégalité il
faut faire attention à ce genre de
résolve revue c'est la substance
elle-même qui étaient interdits mais
vous savez on se d'argent pour certains
ce sont des drogues
pour certains il ya une addiction et
d'ailleurs le responsable de l' agence
qui a été créée l'a bien dit et il l'a
dit avec ses mots à lui il a dit les
joueurs qui ont des problèmes les
joueurs mais c'est vrai système est
gentil il n'arrive pas à se débarrasser
de leur addiction mais il ya aussi un
autre problème vous savez moi je suis
père de jeunes enfants mais qui commence
à avoir accès à internet avaient joué
c'est normal hein on va pas priver des
enfants de 11 12 13 ans d'aller sur
internet
est-ce qu'ils ne vont pas se retrouver
un jour sur ce genre de site et
commencer à jouer il faut être majeur
pour jouer inscrire au préalable enrayer
sa carte d'identité bien un accès
difficile moi ce qui me frappe quand
même c'est que après les élections
régionales
alors qu'on avait vu la défaite de la
majorité qu'il y avait un sentiment
d'injustice très fort dans le pays par
rapport à des choix lourds liés à la
crise économique à la crise sociale à la
crise écologique
la première chose qu'on nous allons
demander de voter nous à l'assemblée
nationale les députés c'est la
légalisation des jeux d'argent et qu'est
ce qui frappe quand même quand vous
regardez la tête des personnes qui sont
soit actionnaire soient dirigeants de
tous ces sites c'est les gens qui
étaient au fouquet's le soir de
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy en mai
donc ça ça crée aussi un sentiment assez
malsain dans le pays
l mercredi en corse et à une très courte
majorité qui a été adoptée à l'assemblée
la réforme des collectivités
territoriales qui prévoit notamment la
création d'un conseiller territorial qui
remplacera les conseillers régionaux et
généraux
276 voix pour 240 contre toute la gauche
a voté contre les centristes se sont
abstenus
avec un président du groupe nouveau
centre particulièrement critique sur ce
texte en écoute
nous sommes favorables à la réforme vous
savez sur les sur les collectivités
territoriales mes textes qui les
proposait latin texte inachevé d'abord
d'abord une réponse inachevé d'abord il
ne règle pas le problème de la parité
prennent du pluralisme dans le mode de
désignation des futurs conseillers
territoriaux
c'est inachevé aussi au plan des
compétences à des amendements ont été
déposés dans deux dernières limites même
pas examiné par le gouvernement donc
vous ne peut pas voter le texte en
l'état moi c'est une porte ouverte
d'ailleurs à ce que la discussion se
poursuivre au sénat
nous sommes pas comme langue commune
parti socialiste qui a fait preuve dans
ce conte ce débat d'un conservatisme
laisse entendre que tout va bien en
france ne change et surtout rien pas
franchement c'est pas responsables vous
êtes d'accord avec françois sauvadet
notamment sur le mode de scrutin
oui je crois que c'est pas tellement et
françois sauvadet si vous voulez le
problème c'est que c'est un rendez vous
manqué nicolas sarkozy comme souvent
avait fait des grands disent qu on
allait voir ce qu'on allait voir la
grande réforme que personne n'avait
jamais voulu faire sur les collectivités
locales il ya eu le comité balladur pour
c'était déjà un peu plus sérieux un peu
plus modérées nounou de l'avion étaient
auditionnés nous avions fait les
propositions qui avait été saluée
d'ailleurs nous avons ensuite rencontré
monsieur balladur après pour montrer
notre bonne intérêt notre bonne foi
vis-à-vis de cette démarche et il y
avait des choses intéressantes
la montagne a complètement accouché
d'une souris et ce qui est pire c'est
que c'est d'une souris manipulées c'est
à dire que c'est la manipulation du mode
de scrutin c'est tout ce qu'il reste
dans ses très bons dans la dose de
proportionnelle c'est l'échec assuré
pour vous aux prochaines années pour la
question c'est l'échec assuré et c'est
que c'est surtout une régression
démocratique
par rapport à ce qui existe alors que
normalement une réforme c'est fait pour
faire des progrès moi j'aurais souhaité
que quand je dis rendez vous manqué ces
rendez vous manqués avec la
décentralisation parce qu'il n'y a pas
de nouvelle décentralisation rendez vous
manqués avec la démocratisation car nous
aurions besoin de démocratisation des
collectivités locales est alors en plus
surtout rendez vous manqué les deux
objectifs que s'était donné le président
de la république c'est-à-dire
simplification et clarification si vous
trouvez et orientale ont inondé c'est
quand même le lam horse d'un
rapprochement entre le département et la
région donc on sûr on supprime une
couche dans le mille feuilles vous savez
c'est vous qui le dites le fait que des
gens cumul des mandats puisque là ils
vont cumuler deux mandats dans deux
assemblées
ça n'a jamais créé de simplification et
clarification en france au contraire ça
plutôt semer la confusion les
financements croisés
on en crève de ça si vous me permettez
l'expression en france toutes ses choux
tout le monde veut s'occuper tout ça
n'aura rien réglé de ce point de vue là
et en revanche on fait un recul sur la
parité à l'égalité hommes femmes dans
les assemblées au niveau des régionales
vous pouvez regarder dans tous les
conseils régionaux il ya une égalité
stricte seulement des sanctions
financières mais tout le monde dit que
ça ne servait à rien regardé aux
législatives ya des sanctions
financières ya même pas 20 % de députées
et es à l'assemblée nationale
appliquerait cette discipline vous de
présenter des candidats et autant que
des candidats n'est que dans des
endroits gagnable nous sommes le seul
parti qui n'a pas de sanction financière
au niveau national et vous avez dit tout
à l'heure que nous sommes trois députés
verts mais vous savez qu'il ya une
élection législative partielle
elle d'ailleurs dans l'ancienne
circonscription de madame boutin et
c'est annie poursinoff notre candidate
qui a été battu de cinq voix seulement
paris social dernière qui se représente
soutenue par le parti socialiste qui a
toutes ses chances de gagner j'invite
d'ailleurs tous les électeurs d i mean à
la soutenir et qui pourraient nous
rejoindre être la quatrième députée
verte de l'assemblée nationale
allez on va passer françois de rugy à la
journée de mercredi avec des
informations qui arrivent au compte
goutte sur la réforme des retraites
c'est donc dans quelques jours que le
gouvernement va faire connaître son
projet précis pour la réforme des
retraites et en attendant ils laissent
filtrer quelques indiscrétions comme
autant de ballons d'essai les dernières
une possible hausse du taux de
cotisation des fonctionnaires est aussi
une taxe sur les plus hauts revenus
supérieurs à 11 milles euros
chloé buffard la cgt a décidé de faire
un cadeau à eric woerth des boîtes
pleines de feuilles de pétition plus de
deux cent quatorze mille signatures pour
le maintien de la retraite à 60 ans
bernard thibault lance un appel à la
mobilisation le 24 juin prochain
il faut le plus grand nombre d'arrêts de
travail possible avec une participation
très forte des salariés du privé et du
public que nous allons naturellement
très rapidement informés sur les
conséquences de la loi
dès que nous connaîtrons la loi mais
encore une fois l'entretien
d'aujourd'hui confirme que tout le monde
va y perdre
des désaccords sur le fond et sur la
forme syndicats et opposition n'apprécie
pas les fuites successives dans la
presse après le report de l'âge légal
des sources gouvernementales ont annoncé
la hausse des cotisations des
fonctionnaires et une texte sur les
revenus de plus de onze mille euros par
mois mais ce qui est curieux c'est la
façon dont procède le gouvernement parce
que finalement il met les partis
politiques à des cars l'idée d'une
conférence nationale le consensus n'a
jamais été formalisée par le président
de la république et même par le premier
ministre a été vaguement évoquée on met
les syndicats allaient cas on en train
de concocter une réforme là dans une
petit frichti dans son coin alors
cafouillage août est de l'opinion pour
l'instant le gouvernement
refuse de confirmer les mesures mais je
voudrais préciser que cette concertation
se maintenant en ce moment-même ces
jours ci hier et aujourd'hui il est
évident que malgré quelques informations
parues ici ou là nous n'avons pas encore
tranché je le dis formellement eric
woerth dévoilera mardi 15 juin le projet
définitif du gouvernement
alors on voit effectivement finalement
le gouvernement a quand même laisser le
temps au débat de s'installer la cfdt
cette semaine a admis le principe d'un
recul d'un allongement pardon tout en
refusant le recul de l'âge légal d'un
allongement des trimestres de cotisation
est-ce que c'est pas malgré tout l'idée
qu' il faudra bien travailler plus
longtemps et c'est ce que va traduire le
gouvernement dans ce projet de loi là
nous n'en sommes plus au stade des idées
générales des propositions générales
nous voyons bien que le gouvernement
c'est un peu une stratégie je sais pas
de l'effeuillage passé parce que l'été
approche donc chaque jour une petite
feuille qu'on nous qu'on nous lâche
comme ça qui on s'aime à tous les vents
alors il y à eut d'abord le recul de
l'âge de la retraite parce que là c'est
clair on va aller au delà des 60 ans il
y a les cotisations soit les
fonctionnaires on nous parle d'une taxe
sur les plus hauts revenus mais ça c'est
dit ce qui devrait vous plaire l'afem et
des revenus de plus de onze mille euros
par mois bon il ya quand même pas
beaucoup de gens qui gagnent plus de
11000 euros par mois et je pense que des
gens qui gagnent des d'autres sommes
pourraient être mis à contribution ne
parle pas des revenus du patrimoine on
ne parle pas des revenus du capital on
ne parle pas du bouclier fiscal
donc on voit bien que en fait comme l'a
dit mon collègue tout à l'heure il y a
un projet qui est déjà ficelé on n'en
lâche par petits morceaux
les éléments il n'est pas négocier n'est
pas négocier il y à des consultations
nous nous avons rencontré monsieur
woerth 1 il a consulté les partis
politiques donc je suis allé avec cécile
duflot le rencontrer il nous a dit il
n'y a pas de négociation ces
consultations décision voilà lui ça ça
mais c'est sur le dialogue social mans
il a la majorité
négocié sa mise en jeu mais terminer je
vous rappelle que les cotisations
sociales dans notre pays
les caisses d'assurance vieillesse comme
les caisses d'assurance chômage elles
sont co géré par les partenaires sociaux
et donc ce serait quand même logique
qu'il y ait une une vraie négociation et
surtout si on voulait faire une réforme
qui sauvent durablement notre système de
retraite par répartition qu'on était
vraiment convaincu tous de la droite dit
qu'elle veut le faire mais elle ne s'en
donne pas les moyens
eh bien on mettrait tout le monde autour
de la table ça prendrait un peu plus de
temps c'est vrai mais on aura eu des
mesures beaucoup plus forte et beaucoup
plus durable vous pourrez discuter de
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
comme on pourrait discuter son niveau
des cotisations s'est amélioré mon
graphique qui va un moment donné ou à
l'eau de rose et parce qu'elle
s'imposait pas tournera une question
démographique c'est une question en
réalité d'efforts que l'on et préfèrent
les verts parce que ce week-end dernier
on n'a pas très bien compris le fond des
propositions des verts mais nous aurons
une position au combat notre conseil
national qui a lieu dans une semaine
donc c'est tout proche c'est une réforme
urgente tant rêver tout à fait mais
enfin nous nous avons pris aussi la
peine de rencontrer les syndicats de
rencontre un certain nombre d'acteurs de
travailler sur des modèles de
financement de doser parce que c'est une
question de dosage c'est pas une mesure
s'élève à pas un allongement de la durée
des que nous nous sommes en tout cas les
défenseurs acharnés de la retraite à 60
ans du droit à la retraite à 60 ans
personne n'est obligé de partir à 60 ans
on est bien d'accord mais on a un droit
et à partir de ce moment là chacun peut
calculer la retraite à laquelle il aura
droit et faire un choix entre travailler
plus longtemps et gagner peut-être un
peu plus ou décider de s'arrêter de
gagner peut-être un peu moins nous
sommes aussi pour qu'il y ait un minimum
pour tout le monde nous fixons à 85% du
smic parce qu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui il
ya quand même des carrières très
erratique des gens qui ont énormément de
mal quoi qu'on fasse
les fonctionnaires celui de philippe
tout à fait mais ça ça me suis rappelé
dans la négociation par exemple si vous
ne faites pas la négociation voulzy
roubles qu'a finalement vous êtes assez
d'accord avec certaines oppositions
ah bah non c'est la mesure phare du
gouvernement c'est la retraite à 63 ans
parce que c'est ça que ça veut dire
nous nous c'est la retraite à 60 ans la
question de la durée de cotisation doit
être mise en balance avec la question du
niveau de cotisations est ce qu'on est
prêt à augmenter les cotisations ou est
ce qu'on préfère allonger la durée de
cotisation c'est ça le débat est ce
qu'on est prêt à trouver des nouvelles
ressources notamment sur les plus hauts
revenus sur les revenus financiers les
revenus de l'épargné valasse qu'il faut
discuter vous avez vu qu'en grande
bretagne un gouvernement conservateur et
libéral a décidé pour les efforts qui
seraient demandés aux britanniques de
faire une consultation populaire
c'est à dire que les gens vont pouvoir
juger qu est-ce qui va pourquoi on ne
l'aurait pas fait sur les retraites
moi j'aurais trouvé ça intéressant quand
ce mercredi en corse et christine boutin
qui se retrouvent dans le collimateur du
canard enchaîné on y apprend que
l'ancienne ministre du logement a été
chargé par nicolas sarkozy de mener une
mission sur le thème de la
mondialisation rémunération personnelle
9500 euros net par mois
en ce mercredi matin l'ancien ministre
communique tous azimuts
cet argent dit elle elle le mérite on
écoute c'est du raisonnement de très bas
étage
quand on est une mission importante et
légitime capital profonde
il faut avoir un minimum de moyens vous
êtes dans mes bureaux vous voyez qu'ils
n'ont rien de luxueux sont corrects mais
non rien d'exclu je n'aurais pas accepté
cette mission
si je n'avais pas un minimum de moyens
donc comme de moyens jeudi soir elle a
annoncé qu'elle renonçait à sa
rémunération pour cette mission elle a
bien fait heureusement mais vous savez
moi j'ose il un petit peu quand je vois
ça entre l'écoeurement et la pitié et
l'écoeurement par rapport à ce système
parce que c'est un système au tour de
nicolas sarkozy pendant 60 en toute
légalité
c'est justement c'est encore plus grave
c'est encore plus grave je veux dire que
on avait un peu à une époque on dénonce
l argent roi mais là j'ai l'impression
que c'est le roi et l'argent tout se
règle avec de l'argent même des
partenaires politiques on les achète
puisque c'est ça que ça veut dire on
parlait départ
jeu d'argent sérieusement penser que
nicolas sarkozy est président de la
république car quand même pas grand
chose à craindre de christine boutin
même par rapport à 2012 ait pu l'acheter
en lui donnant une mission au prix est
vraiment que c'est pour avoir ses
pensées profondes sur la mondialisation
qui lui a donné ce contrat à 9500 euros
par mois avec quatre collaborateurs avec
des bureaux une voiture avec chauffeur
quelqu'un qui a une retraite de député
qui est conseillère générale à côté
c'est une drôle de façon d'aborder et ça
c'est quand même des questions graves
les conséquences sociales de la
mondialisation en s'attribuant un
salaire et en disant que c'est tout à
fait normal de s'attribuer un salaire de
9500 euros par mois c'est plus que le
plafond auquel sont soumis les élus de
la république
les sénateurs et les députés qui cumule
les mandats c'est pas mon cas mais ceux
qui cumulent ils sont plafonnés à 7500
euros par mois ce qui est quand même
déjà pas mal
il faut quand même garder un peu les
pieds sur terre quand on est avec des
responsabilités politiques et ce serait
pareil pour des hauts fonctionnaires on
me dit à m'essayer des hauts
fonctionnaires qui s'empilent et plus
bas est ce que c'est normal
moi j'avais dit une fois quand nicolas
sarkozy était partie en vacances aux
etats-unis et qu'il en avait pour 22000
euros la semaine jaillissent et 22 fois
le smic certains médias vous n'allez
quand même pas tout compter avec le smic
bah c'est quand même un étalon moi je
sais que je tiens c'est démagogique
aussi non à moi je crois que c'est
plutôt le contraire on est en période de
crise on est en période où on sait qu'on
va demander des efforts aux français des
taxes supplémentaires d impôt
supplémentaire ou une retraite plus
petit vous imaginez une personne qui
touchent moi y'a quelqu'un qui est venu
voir un jour dans ma paire l'on s'est
dit vous savez que vous gagner en un
mois ce que je gagne en un an chez qui
risque malheureusement je sais que ça
existe dans notre pays
est ce que vous vous imaginez la
réaction ça peut quand même créé un
sentiment de révolte on a déjà un
sentiment d'injustice est ce qu'on veut
en plus à rajouter dans notre pays un
sentiment de révolte
alors justement christine boutin dont
qui a renoncé à son indemnité a évoqué à
ce propos sont à noter pour cette
mission a évoqué une jurisprudence à
partir de son cas le mini du travail
eric woerth évoque une réforme plus
générale pour rendre impossible le cumul
d'une retraite de parlementaire et d'un
salaire qui serait liée à une fonction
publique comme celle par exemple de
ministre les cas existent thomas raguet
l'a constaté la sphère boutin aura au
moins permis de mettre en lumière une
pratique tout à fait légale
le cumul emploi retraite d'ancien
parlementaire ce matin eric woerth jeté
un pavé dans la mare en proposant des
réformes première c'est de rendre aux
fonds non cumulables car si ça le
problème
le la retraite de parlementaire toucher
sa retraite de parlementaire c'est le
cas de madame boutin et une rémunération
publique liée à une fonction publique
donc je pense que ça c'est aujourd'hui
légal nous pouvons évidemment le rendre
illégal et nous pouvons l'empêcher
christine boutin n'est pas un cas isolé
ce matin henri de raincourt ancien
sénateur et actuel ministre des
relations avec le parlement nous confier
cumuler les deux revenus
je n'ai pas le nombre d'années
nécessaires pour percevoir la retraite
globale de parlementaire
une petite partie sont de tous et et
quand eric woerth demandé que thil
buteur de choisy 2
non ça vous parle
pour un peu précipité ça me paraît pas
jeu ce que je pense c'est qu'en réalité
il faut absolument remettre tout ça à
plat tout remettre à plat ce serait aux
parlementaires d'en décider dans
l'éventualité d'une réforme
pour certains il faudra alors bien
prendre en compte les cas particuliers
de tel
il ya aussi un certain nos collègues
dont je suis qui est sénateur et qui
touche la retraite de fonctionnaires
parce qu'on a dépassé l'âge de 65 ans
maintenant quel âge légal de la retraite
des fonctionnaires c'est pas 60 ans
contrairement à ce qu'en dit le père
thomas parce que j'ai cotisé toute ma
vie était perçu par ce retrait de
fonctionnaires j'aurais été cadres du
privé ça aurait été pareil
la diversité des situations ne manquent
pas outre les activités professionnelles
passées
nombreux sont les parlementaires qui
perçoivent une retraite pour d'anciens
mandats locaux alors roselyne bachelot
reconnu a reconnu un cumul en a parlé
aussi pour michèle alliot marie est ce
qu'il faut prendre ce genre de choses
impossibles au moment d'ailleurs où on
veut développer le cumul emploi-retraite
oui excusez moi c'est pas tout à fait de
même nature
d'ailleurs le cumul emploi retraite on
pourrait en parler parce que si c'est
des gens qui ont une toute petite
retraite et qui sont obligés d'avoir un
emploi à côté ça se comprend et
d'ailleurs c'est un peu choquant qu on
s'oblige et d'en arriver là si c'est des
gens qui ont des retraites assez
importante qu'ils ont acquis notamment
dans la fonction publique notamment le
sait dans l'armée par exemple et
qu'ensuite ils ont un autre emploi
grassement rémunérés ça peut quand même
poser question et là tout ce qu'on voit
c'est quand même scandaleux
enfin je veux dire ce sénateur qui
explique ba oui c'est normal il touche
sa retraite de fonctionnaires alors
qu'il n'a sans doute pas assurer
l'ensemble de ces années de
fonctionnaires parce que c'est ça que
nos concitoyens doivent savoir c'est que
par exemple à l'assemblée nationale
jusqu'à l'année dernière
quelqu'un qui était fonctionnaire qui
était député il pouvait cotiser dans les
deux endroits il travaillait pas dans la
fonction publique mais à la fin il avait
une retraite à taux plein des
actionnaires ça vient juste d'être
d'être finie c'est insupportable tout ça
il faut vraiment mettre de l'ordre dans
tout ça et lorsqu'on certains disent oui
mais concrètement qu'est ce qu'on fait
quand on est aligné sur le régime
général c'est quand même pas compliqué
quand on est un élu et bien c'est comme
un salarié qui changent de fonction
quand ils changent de fonction il garde
pas la retraite de l'ancien fonction de
l'ancienne entreprise tonnerre retraitée
parlementaire et qu'on a on est investi
d'une mission on l'a fait gracieusement
quoi qu'il en soit on la fait
gracieusement soit on abandonne sa
retraite de parlementaire
les choses sont simples sont des
missions précédentes tournées ministre
enfin moi je découvre ça je ne savais
même pas qu un ministre pouvait cumuler
son traitement de ministre
vous savez combien c'est entre dix et
vingt mille euros pour le premier à nice
20 mille euros pour le premier ministre
eh bien il a en plus une retraite de
parlementaire mais lyon on rêve on est
on a complètement décollé de la réalité
c'est pas possible de supporter des
choses pareils au sein d'une république
sachant qu'un ministre reste
généralement assez peu de temps où ils
ont de façon temporaire révèle
aujourd'hui un ministre qui était
parlementaire il retrouve
automatiquement son siège de sénateur ou
député s'il le souhaite d'ailleurs
madame boutin aurait pu le faire et elle
ne l'a pas fait bien là sa retraite
parce qu'elle a plus de 60 ans vous
savez quand même que l'origine de
retraite des députés et les sénateurs
est très lourdement déficitaire
donc ça toutes ces petites choses là
elle aggrave encore le déficit du régime
de retraite des parlementaires
allez avoir le congrès du parti tout
autre chose donc maintenant avant le
congrès du parti ils disent goodbye pc
ça se fasse jeudi la révolte couvait
depuis de longs mois au parti communiste
mais jeudi quelques 200 militants ont
officialisé leur départ du parti parmi
eux les députés patrick braouzec ou
jacqueline fraysse l'ex maire de
nanterre le parti leur semble
aujourd'hui totalement dépassé flora
sauvage ils sont les deux cents 200 a
claqué la porte du parti communiste
m semaine du congrès du pc il souhaite
rompre avec un parti plombé par une
sexuelle dépassé de la politique
moi je kiffe hall communisme je quitte
le parti et c'est plus pour moi le le
parti qui est un obstacle aujourd'hui
justement aller à une hypothèse
communiste que le mot comice lui-même ya
de la déception parce que j'ai pensé
longtemps et je l' ai dit plusieurs fois
j'ai j'ai été très heurté en 2007 de
l'attitude du parti comme et je ne vais
pas quitter parce que j'ai encore voulu
croire j'ai encore voulu penser qu'avec
le résultat de la présidentielle marie
george buffet enfin tous ces événements
le parti communiste allait bouillonnait
dit d aller et puis non pour l'historien
roger martelli ce départ est un cri
d'alarmé lancé à l'ensemble de la gauche
nous pensons que le parti-pris
communiste ce comment dire cette passion
de l'égalité qui est aussi revenu comme
unis restent plus moderne que jamais
mais pour que ce communisme politique
vive il faut qu'ils se changent en
profondeur qui échangent son projet et
pour continuer à répandre les idées
communistes qui les anime
il projette de rejoindre la fédération
pour une alternative sociale et
écologique de clémentine autain un
françois de rugy
le particulier sa voulu s'ouvrir une
stratégie d'ouverture en formant le
front de gauche
et pourtant visiblement ils n'ont pas su
fizi blanc à s'échanger en tout cas pour
beaucoup de responsables avouent avoir
du mal à comprendre autres faisaient
qu'ils avaient les kremlinologues les
spécialistes du kremlin qui savait
décoder le langage du kremlin moi je ne
suis pas un kremlinologues même au parti
communiste français donc j'ai un petit
peu de mal à décoder tout ça je sais que
beaucoup de courants au sein du parti
communiste les découverts puisque nous
siégeons avec les députés communistes à
l'assemblée nationale dans
l'indépendance de des idées de chacun
je pensais je ne suis pas persuadé
personnellement de de l'avenue
ir de la la modernité comme le disaient
certains intervenants du communisme j'ai
du mal à comprendre d'ailleurs ce qu'est
le communisme aujourd'hui ce que je
crois en revanche c'est que le front de
gauche
finalement c'est une démarche qui n'est
pas si éloigné d'ailleurs il paraît
qu'ils veulent s'inspirer d'europe
écologie c'est à dire d'élargissement
d'ouverture de renouvellement de la
gauche on va dire contestataires
protestataires ça je crois que c'est
utile parce que je crois que dans notre
pays et je le vois moi y compris dans
les relations que j'ai avec mes
concitoyens dans ma circonscription et
gens qui sont reconnaissent plus dans
cette gauche confesse qu'il est devenu
impossible on est parti comme l'evo
d'avoir des instances trop centralisée
bon bah c'est sûr que les pratiques
démocratiques mais bon les pratiques des
verts ont toujours été très différente
de celle du parti communiste nous on n'a
jamais été centralisées même parfois
trop mais un militant qui disent que
daniel cohn bendit est un peu trop
présent un peu trop oui c'est différent
ça c'est la relation leader nous n'avons
pas une culture du leadership fort a
parfois ça nous manque un peu d'ailleurs
rassemblement de la gauche est ce qu on
pourrait avoir un rassemblement qui va
de mélenchon à cohn-bendit mais moi je
vous savez j'avais dit avant les
élections régionales que je souhaitais
que ont créé les conditions d'un
dialogue qui puisse déboucher sur un
semblant il faut encore que les gens le
veuille entre qu'ils aillent du front de
gauche même jusqu'au modem en passant
par le parti socialiste et europe
écologie et je crois que depuis les airs
audience très forte je ne va pas rentrer
dans l'est mais oui nucléaire par
exemple le bien sûr la tradition 10 pc
de la cgt c'est pas la même que la vraie
la vue dans le débat sur le grenelle de
l'environnement où le pc a soutenu l'ump
sur les éoliennes contre les éoliennes
bon moi je crois qu'il ya des sujets qui
peuvent nous rassembler et puis surtout
il faut discuter échanger pour voir ce
qui nous rassemble voir ce sur quoi nous
divergent et voir si on peut trouver des
compromis mais ça c'est valable aussi
entre europe écologie au comptant social
encore moi je souhaite en tout cas que
le socle d'une future majorité se soit
europe écologie parti socialiste on
passe à l'actualité
vendredi vendredi c'est jour de foot
et bien évidemment françois de rugy on
ne saurait terminer cette émission 100
par les pronostics football
passeront-ils ou non le premier tour
bien évidemment on a trouvé certains de
vos collègues députés dont qui ont un
avis sur la question
la france on a des bons joueurs mais on
n'a pas de l'équipe
j'espère qu'on va quand même se
qualifier pour les huitièmes mais je
crains que non là je parle en tant que
sportif
cette équipe est là tous les défauts
elle est donnée perdante elle est donnée
trop riches allaient donner trop gâté l
ai donné trop souffrante elle est donnée
trop mal entraînée elle est donnée et
dans de mauvaises conditions
et bien c'est à ce moment là que ça
devient intéressant c'est plutôt bon
signe
généralement quand on est donné gagnant
on perd et quand on est donné perdant on
a plutôt de bons résultats quand on met
en face de l'équipe de france 1 dans la
graduation des choses l'équipe b le
chine et de la faune se fait battre à 0
j'ai regardé le match pied d'une unité
complète excusez moi j'ai pas me de jeu
je suis capitaine de l'équipe de foot de
l'assemblée nationale mais une fois
qu'on a dit ça on n'a rien dit par
exemple une finale brésil-espagne et que
le meilleur gagne
l'allemagne considèrent jamais avoir une
coupe du monde et qui se retrouve toute
manière toujours dans le dernier carré
l'italie c'est exactement pareil la
france
gagne contre le brésil 3 0
très et france brésil 3 0 en finale de
ce mondial le progrès stick à vous
j'aurais bien du mal à livrer un
pronostic mais je ne fais pas de paris
d'ailleurs pour une vision au début
c'est vrai que comme beaucoup de
français on a un peu de mal à comprendre
la stratégie de raymond domenech on en a
peut-être même un peu décrochées par la
passion n'est peut-être plus totalement
là et on est sans doute beaucoup est un
peu nostalgique en effet de 98 parce que
là on avait vibré moi je me souviens
très fortement ou même et l'accord de
2006 pensez à y croire quand même comme
certainement oui moi je suis toujours
attaché au football vous savez à nantes
il ya une équipe de football qui
souffrent aussi beaucoup donc nous
savons ce que c'est nous avoir que deux
là nous nous sentons un peu en empathie
avec l'équipe de france de ce point de
vue là et je crois que j'allais rater
des interruptions de séance pour des
matchs importants
je ne sais pas il faut pas non plus tout
voir le prisme en tout cas je regarderai
les grands matchs de la coupe du monde y
compris si la france n'est plus
sélectionné même si moi je suis un peu
cocardier en la matière donc c'est
surtout la france france a dit merci
beaucoup au delà ce kit est
malheureusement donc on voulait sauter
dans votre tgv pour nantes justement
voilà ils dansent le monde sont la
formule consacrée la semaine prochaine
même lieu même heure au revoir
objectivement 24 ans c'est une vie assez
courte mais subjectivement nous avons
été confrontés en qualité de fille de
jean marie le pen à un grand nombre
d'obstacles dans notre vie et peut-être
cela nous a forgé un caractère combatif
et nous a donné une expérience certaine
du centre des shows de la valeur est
joué comment marine de son prénom se
démarque tel tout en respectant la
marque le pen quel est son style et ce
style lui permettra king effectivement
de succéder à son père cette semaine
nous déshabillons en tout bien tout
honneur
celle que beaucoup a déjà à la tête du
front national déshabillons les démêle
le fond de la forme en revenant sur les
mots et les images qui ont marqué
l'actualité ce soir à 23h45 sur public
sénat bonjour je reçois cette semaine
muriel mayette qui est administrateur
général de la comédie-française et
marcela iacub qui vient d'écrire de la
pornographie en amérique où la liberté
d'expression à l'âge de la démocratie
délibérative
muriel mayette bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous dirigez la comédie française
institution parmi les institutions qui
est aujourd'hui doit avoir trois cent
trente ans à peu près aux mouettes
importance 680 la colonie française
et donc voilà l'occasion pour nous de
faire une sorte de bilan perspectives
avec vous et puis d'aborder quelques uns
des sujets qui vous ont conduit à
innover dans vos fonctions vous avez été
la première femme nommée à la tête de
cette vénérable institution donc voilà
qu'est ce qu'elles sont les grands axes
de ce qui est à venir puisque la saison
là vient de s'achever comment préparez
vous la saison future
d'abord dans la sous le thème de la
diversité parce qu'on fait énormément de
création complémentaires on a 18
créations la saison prochaine et avec
les reprises on a une trentaine de
titres à la fiche entre nos trois salles
mais surtout je développe énormément les
tournées les tournées internationales on
va là à la rentrée prochaine être dans
une tournée historique en russie on va
commencer à novossibirsk on va omsk à
cathérine bourgue moscou saint
pétersbourg et on finit à kaliningrad
avec le mariage de figaro de
beaumarchais et puis aussi on travaille
de plus en plus avec des cinéastes
alors on va venir aussi des cinéastes
qui est une des innovations qu'ici que
vous avez initié précisément mais
auparavant